So Pete, I'm going to talk element widths for a second.
I've heard that relative widths are better suited for responsive design.
Why is that?
Sure. Let's take a look at
this website for a second.
It's got a beautiful, panoramic image that's 1200 pixels wide.
On this laptop screen where the viewport width is 1280 pixels.
No problem, the image fits just fine.
Right.
But now, what happens if you shrink the browser to a size that's below
the image's native width?
Yeah! If I'm not careful,
instead of shrinking and
re-scaling the image, the image will keep its original dimensions.
Users will need to stroll left and right to see the whole image.
Oh.
That's ugly and annoying.
Yeah. It's not a good experience.
On the Nexus 7, about a third of the image is going to get cut off, but
on something like an iPhone 5, the users going to see less than half the image.
They're going to have to scroll left and right to see the whole thing.
Since CSS pixels vary so widely across all these different devices, you
shouldn't count on a specific viewport width for your content to render well.
Large CSS widths or even absolute positions can result in
elements that are either too big or don't fit on the screen at all.
This is why you should use relative positions instead of
absolute positions such as width 100%.